foreign
[Music]
to various places in India I came into
contact with several Artisans who
created textiles right from the heart of
their homes so the idea is to be able to
preserve Heritage craftsmanship which is
amazing it's been passed down centuries
it's really something that all of us can
relate to but material waste might be
something that we don't realize is
happening every day maybe we actually
buy an item we don't realize that
there's a lot of effort and materials
that's being spent in creating it and
you don't always see it
we decided to look at seniors as a whole
we also look at to be seniors people who
are like in their 40s to understand what
would be their aspiration because this
will help us to shape what could be the
future I think personally my grandma is
an elderly dementia so we've been
through that process of going to AIC
agency integrated care in Singapore
those who are really in a kind of state
that need a lot of help and care and has
no family support
foreign
kind of like spring water us because we
could just immediately prototype them
and I think it's true this prototyping
that opened a lot more conversations and
it's through these conversations that we
realized it actually there is a
underlying problem or a bigger issue
which is waste because after going down
the factories we see a lot of bodies
waste right by prototyping with them I
think that also sort of like did the
trust as well
actually it's not about the designs that
we come up with it's not the outcomes
it's it's not this product that we come
up with all these are just mediums for
us to Showcase how we can use these
materials we actually saw more value in
addressing the issue at hand which is
the waste how can we create a model that
is more circular really working in these
factories to figure out how can we
better skill their maybe their daily Ops
like
there was an open call on design
Singapore's website where next Evo gave
a brief so they said that they are
looking for designers who are Keen to
develop products and textiles using
their Yarns there was a lot of synergy
because I on the other hand I'm a
designer looking for sustainable Yarns
that I can use to make into textiles for
my products
in this gdr we are exploring the
feasibility of using pineapple Leaf
textiles but we hope to be able to
broaden that to uses by Hospitality
sector for example for upholstering
their Suites or creating Home Textiles
and goods that can be used by other
Furniture companies or other fashion
companies yeah we've always partnered
with Artisans from day one so in this
case we have batik Artisans as well as
weaving Artisans based in Indonesia so
it is our hope that by scaling the use
of pineapple Leaf textiles and
collaborating with them in a deeper way
it would actually help to Future proof
their craft and preserve Heritage craft
for a long time to come
the photo frame as we call it we know to
the world we have collaborators who are
running assisted living facilities so
when we show them some sample products
on the market so digital frames they
were saying like hey this is really good
really needed because the elderly in
Kobe situation they couldn't have
visitors so this is very helpful for
them so we actually sent it to seniors
living in the assisted living facility
now and we wanted to see what kind of
impact it can bring to their life yeah
besides using it to keep in touch with
their families it was also a way for
them to interact with their fellow
residents
we have Lee Chiang who is our Mentor
speaking to him it's always nice to get
his perspective he's good to have
someone to discuss and remind you of
always promoting the bigger vision for
the elderly and I think that was really
helpful
so what I find meaningful about this
project is that by working with Farmers
pineapple farmers in Thailand they
gained 20 to 30 percent more in terms of
livelihood income than they would have
otherwise so instead of just selling the
fruit now they also are able to sell the
leaves and for communities that are
living on the margins this is
significant in terms of impact to these
communities
when we actually reach out to these
factors and letting them know that we
are backed by Design Singapore I think
that's where they are a little bit more
convinced that we are legit like cannot
be Two Fellas just now eight I want to
take always right so I think that that
helps to spot conversation as well it
really gets people interested in what we
are doing uh and also because of uh the
the Outreach that design Singapore has
provided us more people has reached out
to us some of the factories reach out to
us just because of the Outreach biasing
design Singapore so I'll say that's
where gdr really helped us uh apart from
just the grant is really communicating
with uh more businesses as well I think
the experience of this school design
research project is a very humbling one
what we realized is that there is no one
Silver Bullet to tackle the issues that
we are looking at so I hope whatever we
are doing here will be able to Spur
others on in their own capacity in their
own expertise to collectively build a
better experience a better future for
the elderly
[Music]
foreign